good morning Hank it's Sunday yesterday
I went to the doctor because I have a
bad case of tiny chicken disease so bad
that nothing's coming out of my nose
because the chickens have blocked my
sinus passages and the doctor put me on
an antibiotic and steroids I don't know
why he prescribed me steroids but I
think it's so that I can get really
strong so I can punch myself in the face
and then go in and dig out the tiny
chickens myself so anyway when he was
talking about the steroids he said that
because it raises my blood sugar level
there's one thing that's really
important which is that I not eat any
big sugary meals and I was like well can
I eat 102 small sugary meals and he said
no so the peeps eating is going to have
to wait but I will do it provided that
the doctor eventually says it's okay no
Hank I know that you might be
disappointed by this news but I don't
know where you get off since for like
six months you've owed us one dressing
up as Carrie Bradshaw and you won't do
it and I think I speak for all the
nerdfighters when I say we're mad now
Hank for the last several weeks on the
Ning there have been a series of
discussions about boycotting your videos
until you do the Carrie Bradshaw
punishment until now I have stayed
silent because you are my brother and I
look like you but I can stay silent no
longer
Hank dress up as Carrie Bradshaw I'm
sick and it will make me laugh Willy's
mad about it too Hank
until I see you dressed up as Carrie
Bradshaw and a thumbnail for one of your
videos I'm boycotting hey-hey ho-ho into
a skirt it's gotta go hey hey ho ho into
a skirt Hank's gotta go hey green will
get her views until he wears high heeled
shoes hey green won't get her views
until he wears high heeled shoes that
was the most walking I've done all day
and I didn't enjoy it Hank I'm gonna go
back to bed in a minute but before I do
I wanted to share with you some of my
favorite non don't forget to be awesome
dftba acronyms did for Teletubbies blind
America Decepticons fear the brilliant
Autobots drink fruity tank before
alcohol don't forget that bunnies attack
Hank here's one for your seventh-grade
self dead frogs teach Borden atomists
dorks form the best alliances Starling
fetch the battle axe
and lastly dude find the best acronym
Hank it occurs to me that
some of those would look pretty good
Illustrated nerdfighters if you'd like
upload illustrations of your favorite
dftba acronym to the ning oh okay I'm
gonna go back to bed Hank I'll see you
on Tuesday